en medio de esta mezcla de emociones
tras la derrota de la eurocopa 2020
especialmente de tristeza y frustración
inglaterra amaneció masivamente
rechazando los abusos racistas online
contra los tres jóvenes futbolistas
basterds saca y sancho que ayer cerraron
los tres tiros penaltis frente a italia
el primer ministro en su cuenta de
'twitter' dijo que deben ser tratados
como héroes mientras que el príncipe
william que es el presidente de la
asociación inglesa de fútbol dijo que
esta situación debe detenerse
rápidamente y los responsables deben
responder la policía está investigando
esta situación y esta mañana a través de
un vocero de twitter ha dicho que se han
removido más de 1000 tweets y se han
suspendido permanentemente un número de
cuentas pero la presión aumenta sobre el
primer ministro para que obligue a las
compañías de redes sociales a adoptar
medidas realmente importantes que frenen
este tipo de comportamiento de las
personas a través de redes sociales pero
la jornada de la final de la eurocopa
fue también un caos y anarquía para
londres 49 personas
fueron capturadas 19 policías heridos y
al menos 100 personas ingresaron sin
tener tickets ni pruebas negativas de
kobe al estadio de wembley donde se
estaba jugando la final quienes
asistieron han denunciado que no había
suficiente presencia policial para lo
que requiere un evento de estos de talla
mundial